à 54 ans jean frédéric poisson se lance
à la conquête de sa troisième
législature avec l'étendard du parti
chrétien démocrate depuis 1995 à travers
ses mandats locaux à rambouillet les
rambouillet territoire il cultive son
engagement politique autour de la
préoccupation de la dignité humaine déjà
préfiguré dans le milieu associatif
l'enseignement public et le secteur
privé mais pas seulement
j'ai été confronté au chômage de longue
durée de mon père ce qui la détruit
humainement
donc j'ai j'en ai conçu une vision des
rapports économiques et des relations
économiques qui est pas très libérale je
n'aime pas beaucoup la force des
logiques de marché et la domination des
puissances de l'argent dans l'économie
dans l'entreprise
son slogan de campagne pour cette
élection législative pour l'amour de la
france c'est la volonté de faire que la
france soit à la fois redevienne le
grand pays qu'est lait qu'elle retrouve
toute la place qu'elle doit avoir dans
le concert international et d'un concert
des nations que effectivement là où il
ya des contraintes où il faut des
contraintes avec elles soient précises
mais on sent bien que les français ont
besoin d'oxygène
autre thématique d'engagement la lutte
contre le terrorisme président du
rapport d' enquête sur les moyens de
déchets contrôleurs de la mise en oeuvre
de l'état d'urgence durant la dernière
législature
il veut mettre en avant la problématique
du fait religieux dans la société
je pense que la question d'un dialogue
avec un islam raisonnée et pacifique est
nécessaire et que la fraude la france ne
fera pas l'économie de ce dialogue
un certain nombre d'entre eux doivent
être rejetés combattu condamné sans
aucune espèce
comment dire de faiblesse l'immense
majorité d'entre eux ne demandent qu'une
chose c'est de vivre leur foi
tranquillement dans un espace qui soit
pacifié il faut les aider à cela
face à l'incertitude sur la future
assemblée nationale et la possibilité de
ne pas avoir de majorité claire jean
frédéric poisson défend une conception
transpartisane de son rôle de député la
responsabilité d'un parlementaire c'est
d'abord d'être soucieux de l'intérêt
général
et si jamais ça doit dépasser ses
frontières
eh bien les frontières des partis ou des
groupes pas d'importance face à lui dans
la 10e circonscription des yvelines jean
frédéric poisson aura françois le hôte
du front national jean claude husson du
parti socialiste ou encore le centriste
gilles schmitt cette liste des candidats
n'étant pas définitive